the hunt
you know the drill
predator gets hungry
predator hunts prey
predator kills prey
right wrong
sometimes the prey fights back
team members fall down on the job
major screw-ups abound
but the hunter who pays attention to all
the disasters
survives
now
three top predators show us what it
really takes to make the ultimate kill
africa's fertile savannah is this
lioness's hunting ground
she's the most successful hunter in the
pride
an agile killer with incredible focus
and an awesome track record
her cubs may be the same one day
but right now
they have a one in five chance of
survival
but she can better those odds by hunting
efficiently
she has her hands full the cubs have
just started to eat meat and their
appetites are growing
with the help of wind direction the
lioness can pinpoint the scent of her
prey
today she follows her nose within a few
yards of
warthogs
more of a snack than a meal
but she's an opportunistic hunter and
they haven't picked up her scent yet
she's careful to stay downwind
she even pins her ears and lowers her
head to appear smaller
she melts into the lion colored grass
sneaking closer
before unleashing for the sprint
the warthog has its back to her so she's
in a good position to charge
she can't keep up
others from the pride try to help but
end up stumped watching from the
sidelines
but not all is lost
a piglet
gets separated from his mother
a nice snack for the cubs and the right
size for them to practice on
but warthogs
have guts
this little guy nips back
one moment of distraction and he makes a
break for it
[Music]
it's a fail
what happened is there anyone to blame
for the blunder
first the stalk
lions are built for speed not endurance
they can reach 37 miles per hour but
only for 300 feet
the goal is to stop close enough to
their target
to launch a final sprint without being
noticed
but the lioness ran out of cover into
shorter grassland and her camouflage
trick went to waste
the warthogs spotted her and got a jump
start on their getaway they may look too
plump to hustle but they can run an
impressive 30 miles per hour dashing out
of the danger zone they were way out of
her range of 600 feet
the other lions were too confused to
take action
the one warthog they did get excelled at
nipping and weaving
pretty good defense
the offense pulled off nothing but
sloppy strategy and bad teamwork
with precious energy wasted on a failed
hunt they have to up the ante
if the adults don't eat
the cubs don't eat
they'll weaken and become the target of
other predators
the lioness and her pride regroup
buffalo
one of these horned beasts is a lot
harder to capture than a warthog
but their hunger drives them forward
this time the head huntress opts
for a solo attempt
she doesn't want anyone
ruining her plan
this allows her to get much closer
strong supple shoulders enable her to
keep low and hold her head dead still
during the approach
an adult buffalo is out of reach for a
single lioness but she's a strategist
[Applause]
the calf
is well within her 600 foot strike range
the lion is his claws are retractable
and kept sharp in a protective sheath
when she pounces on her prey she
releases one and a half inch claws and
digs them into the flesh like hooks
the lioness closes in on the kill
but then the plan backfires
[Music]
every buffalo calf comes with a
bodyguard
mother
and every lion fears her
because buffaloes are the meanest herd
of herbivores on the savannah
they're renowned lion killers
a 1 000
archenemy
it's another fail
the lioness's target choice was perfect
she had good grass cover this time and
was able to aggressively attack the back
of the calf
the only thing she failed to predict
was the wrath of the protective mother
and no amount of strategy or planning
could have gotten her around this
obstacle
no one
messes with mother
the lioness knows the solo act was
ambitious
she learns from the mistake and calls
for backup
the hefty mail would be a perfect
accomplice
but he'd rather sit this one out
as male lions often do
the lioness knows he lacks the agility
and stamina required for a sneaky ambush
but he makes up for it in bulk
he considers the invitation
at 550 pounds he's big enough to
intimidate someone's mother
she's got the male support and the hunt
is on
[Music]
there's no cover at all for the lions so
she goes at her target straight on
[Music]
the male looks like he's not sure what
to do but the duo has a plan
she's slowly tiring the buffalo
and the weight of the mail comes in
handy now
but this time
not just mother takes notice
the entire herd
is ready for battle
[Music]
the hunters skillfully take down the
buffalo
the male is the muscle
which frees the female up to take the
throat
the lionesses over two-inch canine teeth
are spaced perfectly to either slip
between the vertebrae of the prey
severing the spinal cord or like with
this buffalo wraps snugly around the
prey's trachea
suffocating it to death
their pylon plan is working and the
buffalo is tiring
over 700 pounds of lion is tough to
shake off
the herd he's not going to just stand by
and watch
they're rallying their own troops
what's worse than a mad mother
many mad mothers
the bond amongst herd members is strong
when one is down the defense goes on the
offense
the lions assess the risk
big bulls weigh 1500 pounds and have a
massive block of horn called a boss that
serves as a battering ram
the bigger the boss the older and more
intimidating the owner
the huntress gives up
she knows that the only dead animal to
come out of this will be a cat
the male is hungry and holds on
but he can't deny the inevitable
it's another fail
the lions couldn't carry out an ambush
on this open ground
so they opted for a direct chase to
startle the herd
they successfully separated an
individual
the male did an excellent job as the
muscle
the lions knew a mother might step into
the ring but they didn't expect a
full-on charge by the entire herd
the duo strategy was spot-on but in this
round of an age-old game
the defense scored big through group
intimidation
[Music]
the pride is not living up to the lion's
killer reputation
they failed three times in a row
they each need over 10 pounds of meat a
day to drive their predatory system
and
they're all hungry
and now
they're getting desperate
and desperation
breeds foolishness
they gang up on a nile crocodile
800 pounds of fresh meat
but covered in scales
and a mouth of daggers
nice try
they're lucky the croc didn't turn them
into lunch
oh for four
they know they need a change of strategy
the first modification
pick on prey that doesn't fight back
buffalo are not the only herbivores on
the dinner menu
the wildebeest are migrating and they
roll right into the lion's territory
these mothers aren't as big as buffalo
mothers and any experienced hunter knows
this
it's fast food
literally
the lions must make their move now
before the herds move on
the huntress just needs to pick
the right target
she falls back on her ambush tactic
using cover to get close
she can sprint 37 miles per hour for 300
feet
which means she has five and a half
seconds to reach her target
[Music]
she's so hungry she wants to pounce now
if she doesn't hold back
her ambush will backfire
suddenly a second lioness startled a
herd from the side
it's now or never to make the perfect
hunt
the lioness waits patiently for the
right moment
but a second hunter jumps the gun and
attacks from the flanks scaring the herd
the first lioness bursts from cover
[Music]
they isolate the target
while the females distract the
wildebeest the male moves in from behind
he's rehearsed this plan
this time it works
finally they'll eat and so will their
cubs
what made this hunt
so much more successful than the buffalo
bust
first
the grass was taller providing perfect
cover for the ambush
lions are fast sprinters but not long
distance runners
getting close to the kill zone was key
that's the immediate area around the
prey
a perceived boundary that a predator
must cross unnoticed in order to outrun
the prey in this case
90 feet from boundary to target the
first lioness bursts from cover
the next hunter jumped too soon but in
fact her move drove the herd closer to
the first hunter
after the lionesses tired the prey out
the male's unmatched weight and strength
delivered the final blow
but the most important tactic may have
been avoiding prey that fights back
nothing like learning from losing
a wildebeest may be half the weight of a
buffalo
but some dinner is better than none
a solo lioness has a one in five chance
of making a kill
and a pride success rate rises to one in
three
what separates the winners and losers is
how they handle defeat
this pride has persisted
and now the cubs have a good chance of
surviving
the last herds leave this pride's
territory
will the beast follow the constantly
moving rains and the fresh grass that
erupts in its wake
but it's not always greener on the other
side
soon they'll have to cross
the dangerous mara river
and the predator that inhabits its
waters
the nile crocodile
it's the largest crocodile in africa
reaching 20 feet and weighing over a ton
the crocodile is a sit and wait predator
that unleashes epic speed seconds before
a kill
it's less known
for its epic mistakes
it's quiet on the river now
but the crocs know
millions of wildebeest and thousands of
zebra will soon have to cross it
between migrations they live off very
little sometimes just small fish and the
fat stored in their tail
during the drier winter months they've
been living in east ovation where their
metabolism almost grinds to a halt
but summer is here and the 90 degree
heat stirs their hunger
if they don't make at least one kill
during the annual crossing they won't
survive another year
the wildebeest and zebra are still a
ways off
but buffalo are arriving now
the crocs are dying for me
female crocodile positions herself
within three feet of the prey
without detection
she's like a spy submarine
eyes and ears exposed for surveillance
while the rest of the body hides
underwater
to the buffalo she could be a floating
log
but this log has teeth
it's a tug of war what happens next
defies the logic of the hunt
this is the crocs first taste of red
meat in nine months
but the buffalo is not sticking around
for lunch
[Music]
it's a fail
what went wrong
she got within three feet of her target
without incident by exposing only her
eyes ears and nose
binocular vision allowed her to judge
the distance between her jaws and her
prey
the vertical leak was fast
quarter second to go ten feet
the crocs grip is all it's got to make a
kill
if it doesn't clamp its jaws down in the
right spot
it'll lose its meal
her biggest mistake
was taking on a 1500 pound animal
nine months without a decent kill has
forced the hunter to bite off more than
she can chew
luckily
more meat on the hoof approaches croc
territory
rain brings over one million wildebeest
ever closer
they move in the relentless pursuit of
fertile grasses
every year it's the same path
and every year
they end up here
the darkest part of their journey
they must cross to reach the food on the
other side
but in doing so
they risk swimming head first
into death
the adults have done this before but
they know what's waiting
thousands of lives will be lost at this
crossing
but the majority will make it through
the crocs feel the movement of the
approaching herd
pressure sensors on their skin are more
sensitive to vibrations than human
fingertips
they take up their positions
it's each to his own
but everyone's got the same idea
the crossing begins with one brave
plunge
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the croc has chosen a position in the
path of a zebra herd
she plans an interception
zebras are surprisingly strong swimmers
she can't decide on which to attack
she's trampled
she turns downstream to a different mark
wildebeest
already a few crocs are lined up
the prey knows the danger
they boldly forge ahead
not just toward their enemies
but over them
their strategy is to use large numbers
and herd perseverance to overwhelm their
reptilian predators
it seems to work
suddenly a softer target appears
this foe has never crossed the mara
without experience or muscle he's at his
most vulnerable
it takes 30 seconds
for a zebra to cross the mara river
the most perilous few moments in the
foal's life
[Music]
the fall swims as fast as his hooves can
take him to the other side
he heads directly into the trap
but this newbie dodges the jaws of our
hungry croc plus two others
so far the big bonanza is a big fail for
the croc
how did both the wildebeest and the
zebra make it through the most powerful
jaws on the planet
[Applause]
the wildebeest had momentum and
adrenaline on their side
they moved toward the crocs coming at
them from the side
making the crocs position too awkward
for a swift attack
crocodile eyes are forward oriented they
had to move their heads to the side to
see and this slowed them down
and a hoof to the skull probably didn't
help their concentration
the crocodiles were too slow to get
their strategy in order
and the full
pure luck
even with the glut of the migration
these crocs have a tough life
and with every failed attempt they're
wasting more valuable energy
the croc is on a mission
triggered by the fury of starvation this
time
she waits for an animal to drift away
from the herd
the zebra has almost made it to the
other side
he recovers from a dunk and is within
inches of the
bank
[Music]
yes the croc can't get a good angle so
she moves downstream letting the current
push the prey towards her
powerful muscles exert a bite force of 5
000 pounds stronger than a t-rex
like a bear trap the crocodile's
cone-shaped teeth interlock around the
prey's flesh
the crocodile can eat up to half its
body weight in one sitting that's a
potential 450
pound meal the clever design of the
teeth is made for gripping
not chewing
it's a stalemate
the crocodile can't get a good grip and
the zebra can't get out of the river
[Music]
a victory for the zebra
but for the croc
another epic fail
as holes in the crocs strategy become
apparent
we see it's got more vulnerability than
meets the eye
the great crossing is the crocs last
chance to bulk up until next year's
migration
it's now or never
these are the herds last stragglers
the croc is ravenous but she can't let
hunger cloud her precision
she weighs all the variables
[Music]
the speed of the current
the direction of the zebra
the size of her target
what did she finally do right
she isolated a young inexperienced
target
like the previous attempt near the bank
she used the current to her advantage
only this time she positioned herself
closer to the bank so she could push off
of it and raise herself high enough to
clamp down with a bite
that simultaneously drove her victim
under
patience and planning
saved precious energy for the final
attack
it was the recipe for a flawless kill
this zebra will sustain her for months
the reputation of the croc
is that of an impeccable killer
the reality is 50 percent of its hunts
end in failure
like the lion it learns from its
blunders and rebounds
as its kind has done for millions of
years
the lucky survivors from the herds have
made it through the mara river
but now
they enter the territory
of another hunter
the cheetah
this cat fills a niche on the savannah
while lions use pride tactics and
crocodiles have strength the cheetah's
prized skill is speed
it's the fastest mammal on the planet
getting from zero to 60 in three seconds
the cheetah's flexible spine and
extended limbs allows it to cover 40
feet in one stride
and at full speed the cat is actually
airborne for most of its stride
its flattened tail acts like the rudder
of a boat and helps balance the
cheetah's body as it runs
the cheetah may lose points for strength
and weapons
but who needs them when you've got a
ferrari engine
a fast engine requires a lot of fuel and
if these brothers don't get a kill soon
they'll lose their best assets
[Applause]
male cheetahs are collaborative cats
once they reach adulthood they often
form long-term hunting coalitions made
up of brothers
[Music]
an adult zebra can weigh 850 pounds
eight times heavier than a cheetah
the cheetah's size and strength can't
compare with this target
so good teamwork is crucial
luckily
these zebras are distracted
speed
might just be enough today
[Music]
the first brother starts the ride of his
life
cheetah brother number one has singled
out his target
a zebra foal
the mother fends him off
number two tries to pick up where his
brother left off
he can only keep up this incredible
speed for about 20 seconds
the foal outruns him
double fail
the plan
seemed like a good idea at the time
the distracted heroes gave the brothers
a chance to stalk in close
the dip in the savannah was the perfect
place for brother number one to launch
an attack
and the open ground allowed the cheetah
to get to almost 70 miles an hour in
three seconds flat
but he underestimated the mother's
blocking skill
she successfully positioned herself
between the cat and her full twice
brother number two picks up the sprint
but by then the foal was way ahead
zebra are slower than cheetahs they can
only reach 40 miles per hour
but their stamina can keep them ahead of
their pursuer
whereas cheetahs can sprint for only 900
feet
at their top speed cheetahs have just
five seconds to snag their prey
or the sprint goes to waste
and
they don't eat
cheetahs must eat at least every five
days
they're cooperating now but soon they
may be competing for territory and
females
strength
and defense of their territory may
determine the outcome
the brothers come across a large herd of
thompson's gazelles
but quantity of the prey
doesn't determine quality of the hunt
to a cheetah sight is paramount
the eye has a sharp wide angle view
which can maintain focus at high speeds
the coalition plans an ambush from two
angles
brother number one
starts the sprint
he chases the prey right into the path
of brother number two
but it weaves its way out of the trap
[Music]
the gazelle zigzags are an adaptive
strategy that break the cheetah's speed
[Music]
another bust
how did they get it so wrong
the stock was a good start
the gazelle didn't immediately notice
his approach
as planned
the gazelle ran towards the second
hunter
but the praise speedy sidestep out of a
cheetah dead end caught the hunters by
surprise cheetahs are fastest when
running in a straight line
but they lose momentum when they're
forced to turn
the longer the chase
the greater the chance of losing the
kill
if their pace is broken
the cheetah's awesome speed amounts to
nothing
one brother decides to ditch the other
hoping for better odds going it alone
group hunts are powerful
but more can go wrong
first things first
get close
or get nothing at all
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's short and precise
a perfect execution
what made this hunt
work for the offense
a silent stalk
and a flawless chase put the cheetah's
chances right up there this time it
trailed the gazelle's side steps without
error
but the clincher
was when the cheetah tripped the gazelle
cheetahs don't have the bulk and
strength of their cousin cats so they've
come up with other ways of taking down
prey like swiping a hoof
[Music]
a dramatic end to a dramatic hunt
he did it all on his own
which means he doesn't have to share his
hard-won meal
while he's having a protein party for
one
the other brothers are just barely
hanging on
perhaps they should try solo hunts as
well
instead
they double their forces
two more males join in they will not be
upstaged by their renegade brother
with four attacking from different
angles they're banking on going to bed
with full bellies tonight
[Applause]
a lone impala
without a herd to help look out for
predators
it's practically on the plate already
but the brothers
are in for a ride
the first sprint gets him close
he covered 100 meters in seven seconds
that's over 60 miles an hour
right on top of the prey at first
enter from the sides some eagerly
others
leisurely
[Music]
even under the strength of four cheetahs
the rams still not giving it
finally
the band of brothers triumphs
a good stranglehold
ends the battle
what went right
a closed stock
lightning chase
and powerful grip
got them ahead
then the closing in
the last two look lackadaisical but in
fact they deployed their moves at
calculated intervals slowly and
deliberately
to save energy for the critical moment
[Music]
whether solo or together
these cheetahs will do just fine and
when the females enter their territory
they'll be fit enough to prove it
cheetahs procure a meal with one out of
two attempts
that gives them the highest batting
average of all africa's big cats
the prey they get sustains them until
the next time
the prey that gets away
teaches them how to change their game
because
what is born of defeat
is perseverance
and with it
survival
[Music]
you